so what we have seen now is that our
first amendment press the people who
love the first amendment the most
those folks have decided that cancel
culture literally does not exist it is
not a reality
it does not exist in any way shape or
form and if you talk about it it's
because you're trying to distract
you really shouldn't be talking about
about cancellation and destruction
and book burning you shouldn't talk
about any of that stuff because if you
talk about that stuff it's a distraction
from the real issues
now let's be quite clear about this the
book burning the cancellation
all it is designed to do is create an
ever-changing standard
a constantly shifting and moving line
that anybody could find themselves of
on the wrong side of at any time because
what that does is it creates
an innate level of power for the
institutional left
if they can cancel you at any time for
any reason then everybody lives in fear
they self-censor which is what happened
with the dr seuss's state right they
pulled down
these books that were supposedly racist
which again millions of people have read
to their children
none of those if anyone can provide me a
study on how dr seuss made kids more
racist i'm willing to hear it
seriously bring it bring me a piece of
data name me
the member of the alt-right who grew up
looking at the page of if i ran the zoo
over and over and over again to decide
on white supremacy
it doesn't exist because that's stupid
okay same thing with mcgillicutt's pool
which has like a fish that looks like an
eskimo
and this is supposed to be terrible or
it's a thing that i saw it on mulberry
street
which has a picture of a chinese person
holding chopsticks
like that has not made any single human
being in the united states more racist
none okay but if you sound off about
this then this means
that you are racist yourself right and
if you sound off about cancel culture
generally it's because you're not okay
with american change right this is the
the case that i was talking about last
week that was made repeatedly by members
of the media that really if you're
against things being canceled
what you're really in favor of is the
racism is the brutality is the cruelty
okay cancel culture doesn't exist so cnn
had an entire segment with john avalon
and margaret hoover
slamming the gop and fox news for
focusing on dr seuss
so again it wasn't the gop and fox news
that decided to get six dr seuss books
canceled it was the left that decided to
do that
and then the right side i thought book
burning was bad and then the left says
why are you even focusing on book
burning
because book burning is bad let me
explain it real slow for you book
burning
is bad but apparently even paying
attention to it is just a distraction
tactic
here uh the geniuses over at cnn let's
have a reality check about dr seuss for
one second and i love dr seuss
it was not cancelled okay his estate
decided they would stop publishing
several books because they contained
illustrations that
most people if looking at them
objectively would say oh that's pretty
racist now you can debate on
individual books but let's have the
individual uh
images that cause the estate of dr seuss
to be feel uncomfortable and have people
defend them
this is not a cancel culture moment this
is a distraction play
and it should not be occupying so much
headspace
okay so this is the move that folks on
the left like to make when they actually
want to restrict rights
think back to charlie hebdo remember the
charlie hebdo shooting so
islamist terrorists decided to murder a
bunch of people at the french
essentially mad magazine charlie hebdo
because they drew
a perverse picture of muhammad in a sex
act or something
and do you remember that the hashtag i
am charlie hebdo trended
in the west because the idea was that
you may not like charlie hebdo they drew
a bunch of stuff that was
i thought extraordinarily anti-israel
bordering on the anti-semitic
okay but they have every right to do
that i am charlie hebdo
the idea was that even stuff that you
don't like ought to be defended as an
exercise of free rights
now the move by cnn is the opposite if
you are not willing to defend a single
dr seuss
page right the one that people are upset
about then this means
that you are actually a hypocrite right
you have to defend the page in order to
defend the right of that book to still
be distributed
now i'll be completely honest with you
i'm willing to defend if i ran the zoo
as a book
i am willing to defend the i'm willing
to defend
and to think that i saw it on mulberry
street on the basis of a simple fact
those books have not produced more
racism in american society by
any measurable level by any measurable
you cannot find an
uh individual who's been made more
racist by if i ram the zoo not one not a
single human
okay in other words you're looking for
things to be offended by and then when
you find something that you are offended
by
you say isn't this objectively offensive
and then people who were never offended
by it before they go back and they're
like oh that does look kind of
uncomfortable and then they say let's
get rid of the literature that is not
the way
a free society ought to operate instead
people ought to be able to consume what
they want to consume
and by the way people can use their best
judgment and know
these materials are not making people
more racist it's absurd it's an absurd
contention it always was an absurd
contention
but the idea from cnn now is that if you
are
if you don't think if you don't love
that particular picture in a dr seuss
book
how dare you criticize the doctor suit
of state for taking the stuff down
okay so kevin mccarthy the gop leader he
decided to defend doctors who would read
green eggs and ham which
doesn't make a ton of sense to me
because green eggs and ham is not one of
the books being cancelled
i would have read and to think that i uh
to think i saw it on mulberry street or
if i ran the zoo i would have just
gotten up here and i just would have
read it
because again even if i don't love those
particular images
even i could see why somebody might find
them offensive they have not offended
generations of children or made anybody
racist
but jake tapper tweeted out one of the
weirdest parts of this culture war is
that the self-styled warriors
aren't willing to stand by the
empirically racist images they're
supposedly defending
green eggs and ham is not one of the
books the dr seuss foundation has
decided to stop publishing
okay now here is where it gets weird you
don't even have to defend those books to
defend the right of those books to be
distributed
right you don't you can actually say i
don't like those books i don't want
those books in my house but
people should be able to buy those books
that is true for virtually all books
i think there are tons of books that
offend me and i think are annoying and
stupid
i don't think they should be banned i
think objectively speaking
virtually all books written by members
of the new york times op-ed page are
moronic
i don't think any of those should be
banned it's a bizarre
bizarre contention right it's the same
contention as we should get rid
of freedom of speech because some people
say the n word
okay so i think that freedom of speech
protects people saying the n word
that doesn't mean they're protected from
societal consequences but they but
freedom of speech does protect the n
word
am i defending the n word no i think the
n word is awful and evil i don't think
anybody should use it black white or
green
and i do understand the differences
between people of different races using
it
hey but i don't like the n word i think
it's an ugly word and i think it should
be extirpated
from our use of language does that mean
that you don't have the right to say it
of course you have the right to say it
you don't have to defend material in
order to understand there is a right to
use material or see material
that's an absurdity okay but the the
move of the left is twofold one is
you're not even willing to defend that
picture so that picture shouldn't exist
and two is why are you even worrying
about all this stuff sure we're trying
to cancel random stuff but
you know what are you worried about and
the answer is as you keep evolving the
standard so as to maximize your own
power
there is no standard the standard just
continues to get broader and broader
so over the weekend we saw an attempt
now to go after speedy gonzales and pepe
le pew right notice how they're going
after all the kids stuff
and the reason they're going after all
the kids stuff is because they only want
their standards taught in school so it
is very dangerous for your kid ever to
watch a pepe le pew
cartoon but it is also dangerous for you
not to teach your four-year-old boy that
he might be a four-year-old girl
in fact it is mandatory that you teach
your child about cross-dressing when
they're five
very important you teach your kid about
the virtues of cross-dressing but if
they watch a bug's bunny cartoon in
which he cross dresses for humorous
purposes
then this is very bad and in fact
terrible and you can't do that
don't worry they're not trying to
control your kid's mind they're not
trying to control how your kids are
brought up
the same culture that says that cardi b
is excellent for teenagers
says they cannot read a dr seuss book
lest they become racist
yeah i don't trust you guys well jahad
ali
who's an idiot columnist for the daily
beast he said we are fighting about
speedy gonzales dr seuss and potato head
the right wing is raising funds off it
and we'll use it in 2022 for elections
zero republicans voted for the relief
bill over half a million people are dead
there is a recession what a dumb nutty
country
well i mean first of all why should they
vote for the crappy relief bill it was a
bad relief bill
over half a million people are dead and
would be dead regardless of whether you
were canceling people it turns out that
book burning is a bad idea
and so is going back and removing old
cartoons and you can
show these to your kids or not show them
to your kids and you can textualize them
or not contextualize them
it is my job to raise my kid not your
job to raise my kid
is the push and again if you think it's
going to end with like a few dr seuss
books here's the thing they already
showed their neck
they're going to come for cat in the hat
you know that's next they've already
accused cat in the head of minstrel c
in some bizarre iteration again cancel
but don't worry
it's all in your head cancel culture
doesn't exist there's a piece by aj
willingham over at cnn
called it's time to cancel this talk of
canceled culture what exactly is
canceled culture is it someone getting
fired for harassment or problematic
views
no that's a workplace doing its job oh
is that what it is
even though you didn't define
problematic is it a popular figure
losing fans or affiliations because of
past actions
no that's the power of public opinion or
it's cancellation depending on the
content of the past actions and its
impact on their current job
my favorite part of this particular
piece from cnn is that they actually
cite this this idiot author actually
cites gina carano as not being cancelled
because we hired her at daily wire
she was canceled and then we hired her
and what do you not understand about
this but again if you point out that
there is a censorious
move on the left then you are somehow
either delusional or participating in
cruelty and malice
by the way as far as pepe pew goes the
entire joke of pepe le pew is that he
was a pervert
that was the entire joke he loses pepe
le pew is a bad guy
that's the whole point of his character
people like pepe le pew forwards rape
culture again show me the person who
watched pepe le pew and then raped
somebody
is this common in the rapist community
i'm unaware it seems to me that if
you're going to connect
content with effect which is what you
guys love to do right you like to
suggest
that donald trump is responsible for
riot on the capitol because he said
stuff and then people
ignored the peaceful part and went
rioted at the capitol but the content
was connected with the action so show me
how the content was connected with the
action with pepe le pew show me the
rapist who was desperately watching pepe
le pew
late at night and then decided to go
participate in quote unquote rape
culture
it's it's so bizarre and again there's
no end to it of course
they're the when when they say the dr
seuss so the original defense of the
whole dr seuss thing was
don't worry we're just stopping the
distribution of new books but you can
still go to the library and get the
books
cbs then called up libraries and asked
whether they would remove dr seuss books
okay which is when journalists do this
sort of stuff when they call up
libraries when they get the intelligent
idea
to start calling places and asking
whether they're gonna remove material
that is not journalism that is activism
it's a soft way of pressuring these
libraries into doing just that
so they called up these places and as it
turns out yes there are now libraries
that are going to start removing this
stuff
that was breaking as of this morning
there are libraries who are going to
start removing
these books from the shelves so that you
cannot see these terrible terrible
images and everything that stops there
it doesn't of course levar burton
who used to be the reading rainbow guy
nellivar burton's the the band the
reading guy
he says you know there's some twain
books that don't age particularly well
maybe you should ban huck finn
talk about how you've seen this evolve
over time i'm sure there are books that
maybe you've read or seen that were you
know popular or bestsellers that in
retrospect you might look at and go
that didn't age very well sure
well i mean there are plenty um
tom sawyer huck fan they didn't age very
well guys i mean if they didn't age very
well probably we should remove them
probably that's the best particular
thing we could do is just get rid of
material
and we can indoctrinate your children at
the same time by virtue of just
cleansing the marketplace we can just
cleanse it
this is why california is now proposing
to ban
boys and girls sections at big retailers
you literally will be
you'll go to a toy store and they won't
have boys and girls sections anymore
it'll be banned
you'll be punished for saying that boys
and girls are different even though
just a note boys and girls are different
and they don't like the same toys i have
a boy i have two girls
and they don't like the same toys and it
makes it easier for me to shop
when the toys are segregated by gender
that does not mean that i can't go over
to the boy section and buy my kid escape
i literally bought my daughter a
skateboard yesterday okay
kind of a boy toy so what it's fine
but the notion that it's doing some sort
of heart some terrible psychological
harm
horrible harm to have a boys and girls
section of a toy store is idiotic
in the extreme but this is this is the
culture we want
it has to do with indoctrination it has
to do with cramming down a particular
vision
of society and it extends over into the
tech sphere as well by the way
apparently both google and urban
dictionary are now censoring particular
terminology
one of those pieces of terminology that
they are censoring
is the term blue anon so the term blue
anon
which was used recently by our friend
candace owens and that term
refers to all the conspiracy theories
the left has bought into over the past
few years right everything from the
russia collusion hoax to the brett
kavanaugh rape stuff to jesse smalley
to all of that so google and urban
dictionary literally removed
that term blue and on they took it down
i've never heard of a word being banned
at any of these places but
apparently google has censored searches
for blue and on you cannot even search
for it now
also by the way google totally games its
own system
google is actively suppressing search
results that do not
acquiesce to traditional viewpoints of
the left i i recommend that you install
duckduckgo on your computer rather than
google as a way to combat
all of this so the left is changing how
you can
receive information they're teaching
what kind of materials your children can
access
so yay on the on the transgender
propaganda
nay on the old dr seuss books and we are
all supposed to just acquiesce to this
and pretend that this is not in any way
a violation of individual freedom
or a change to the culture that is bad
you're supposed to just say well you
know that's the way the world works
or we could stand up and just say no
that's the other thing we could do
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content